depuis trois jours la famille Arcan
passe son temps ici ils entèrent leur
mort les uns après les autres le plus
jeune un bambin de 4 mois à peine ils
ont célébré 8 funérailles jusqu'ici ils
n'ont pas fini tu auras de sortir
de réaliser notre planète immense là on
parle mais on ne sait pas comment on y
arrive c'est qu'une foule apocalyptique
on est très affecté
aujourd'hui Suzanne 47 ans et sa fille
jerenne 14 ans viennent rejoindre Homer
lui a été enterré il y a deux jours
Homère a pourtant été retrouvé en vie
sous les décombres de la maison
familiale faycel le fils aîné d'Homère
la déterrer à Manu
j'ai creusé creuser avec mes mains j'ai
des blessures partout sur les jambes
aussi
[Musique]
cette annoncellement de débris et métal
tordu c'était un hôpital et survivant
attendent horrifié à la vue des pelles
mécaniques qui creusent sans plus faire
attention à ceux qui pourraient par
miracle avoir survécu
les en viennent photos en main demandez
des nouvelles des leurs
corps sont mises en terre à la pelle
leur tombe cernée de blocs de ciment
similaires à ceux qui ont mis fin leur
vie en s'effondrant il faut faire vite
et avec ce qu'on trouve
si seulement les secours avaient été
présents plus rapidement on en serait
pas là 10 les familles aussi
anéanticamer les années
ils ont traité ça comme un chantier de
construction normale comme si c'était
vide en dessous mais il y avait beaucoup
de vivants on entend des voix il nous
disent qu'il n'y en a pas si nous
avaient aidé le premier jour si l'État
avait été là le premier jour la plupart
aurait survécu il n'y aurait pas eu
autant de mort
dans les ruines disquanderoon et de tant
d'autres villes c'est aussi la confiance
envers le gouvernement turc qui
s'effondre et qui est emporté par les
codes sanglots
ici Marie-Ève Bédard Radio-Canada
islandero